- We're told, divide the polynomials.
The form of your answer should either be
just a clean polynomial,
or some polynomial plus some
constant over x plus two,
where p of x is a polynomial
and k is an integer.
Fair enough, and if we were
doing this on Khan Academy,
this is a screen shot from Khan Academy,
we would have to type this in,
but we're just going to do it by hand.
And, like always, pause this video
and try to do it on your own
before we work through it together.
All right, now let's
work through it together.
And what we're trying to
do is divide x plus two,
into three x to the third power
plus four x squared
minus three x plus seven.
And so, like always,
we focus on the highest
degree terms first.
x goes into three x to the
third power how many times?
Three x squared times.
We'd want to put that in
the second degree column.
Three x squared.
Three x squared times
two is six x squared.
Three x squared times x is
three x to the third power.
There's something very meditative
about algebraic long division.
Anyway, we'd want to
subtract what we just wrote
from what we have up here.
So let's subtract.
And these characters cancel out.
And then four x squared
minus six x squared
is negative two x squared.
Bring down that negative three x.
And now we would wanna say,
hey, how many times does x go
into negative two x squared?
Well, it would go negative two x times.
Put that in our first degree column.
Negative two x times
two is negative four x.
Negative two x times x is
negative two x squared.
Now we wanna subtract what
we have here in orange
from what we have up here in teal.
So we either put a negative
around the whole thing
or we distribute that negative
and that becomes a positive,
that becomes a positive.
And so this is equal to, the
x squared terms cancel out.
Negative three x plus four x
is just going to be a straight up x.
Bring down that seven, x plus seven.
How many times does x go into x?
Well, one time.
Actually, let me do a,
use a new color here.
So, how many times does x go into x?
It goes one time.
Put that in the constant column.
One times two is two.
One times x is x.
We wanna subtract these characters.
And we're left with
seven minus two is five.
And so, we can rewrite
this whole thing as,
we deserve I guess a
little bit of a drum roll.
Three x squared minus two x plus one,
plus the remainder,
five, over x plus two.
One way to think about it is,
hey, I have this remainder,
I'd have to keep dividing it by x plus two
if I really wanted to figure
out exactly what this is.
Now if I wanted these expressions
to be completely identical
I would put a condition on the domain
that x cannot be equal to negative two
because if x was equal to negative two,
we'd be dividing by zero here.
But for the purposes of this exercise,
you just have to input
this part right over here,
you'd have to type it in,
which I guess isn't the easiest
thing to do in the world.
But it's worth doing.
All right, see you in the next video.